keeping children safe in a world of  social media that was the theme today as  the senate committee grilled big tech  heavyweights execs from youtube tick  tock and snapchat took questions at  issue how their apps are looking out for  children on issues from privacy to  safety that follows testimony from a  facebook whistleblower who says  instagram can be seriously harmful to  teens lawmakers also expressing concern  that ticktock is tied to china's  communist government which the ap's  parent company denies if it were not  accurate you would answer the questions  and you have dodged the questions  more than any witness i have seen in my  nine years serving in the senate  lawmakers say they are considering bills  to hold social media companies more and  more accountable